madame la ministre la parole est à
présent jean claude carle pour le groupe
ump
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur les gens du voyage qui
parcourent notre territoire en grand
nombre cause pour certains d'entre eux
assez régulièrement désordre et violence
et je voudrais par deux exemples montré
combien les élus sont impuissants et
désarmé devant des attitudes ignorant
nos lois ignorant le droit des
populations à vivre tranquillement je ne
ressens aucun sentiment discriminatoire
envers ces communautés qui ont un mode
de vie différent et que je respecte
nulle volonté pour moi donc de les
stigmatiser mais simplement la volonté
de montrer la réalité dimanche 16 juin
alors qu'une manifestation sportive se
dérouler sur le terrain communal de
frangy en haute-savoie 70 caravanes de
gens du voyage ont voulu s'y installer
délaissant une aire d'accueil une aire
d'accueil situés à proximité
l'adjoint au maire s'est interposé en
déclinant sa qualité d'élu il a été
violemment prise à partie n'est qu'à ces
quinze jours d'arrêt de travail
profondément choqués d'avoir été
violenté sous les yeux de 150 jeunes
enfants et notamment de son fils de 10
ans les forces de l'ordre sont
intervenues et je tiens à saluer et à
rendre hommage à l'action du préfet et
des gendarmes et ils ont été donc
dirigés vers une autre aire d'accueil
mais personne n'a été inquiétée alors
qui hier un jeune homme qui manifestait
devant m6 dimanche lors de l'émission du
président de la république a été
condamné en comparution immédiate à deux
mois ferme assortis d'un mandat de dépôt
il y aurait-il deux poids deux mesures
effectivement le jeudi 23 mai à montrer
20 en seine et marne épisode similaire
son maire a d'ailleurs écrit à monsieur
le ministre de l'intérieur lui
expliquant le déroulement de cette
journée 200 caravanes d'une communauté
liées à la mission évangélique des
tsiganes de france ont forcé le passage
pour s'installer sur un espace vert
intercommunale protéger le maire a lui
aussi été l'objet de menaces
et d'intimidation verbale et physique
il se souvient des dégradations
occasionnées par de précédents passages
qui ont coûté des centaines de milliers
d'euros un coût exorbitant pour toutes
les communes qui connaissent ce genre
d'assez dégrade malgré la bonne volonté
des élus le phénomène prend de l'ampleur
en raison du nombre de plus en plus
important des gens du voyage de leurs
exigences et de leur comportement ils
ont des droits certes ils ont aussi des
devoirs mais comment pourrait-il le
comprendre tant les messages envoyés aux
délinquants alors madame la garde des
sceaux qui qui dit nos prisons sont
pleines mais vide de sens sont
déresponsabilisant alors madame la
ministre comment envisagez-vous de leur
faire respecter la loi de la république
comme à tout citoyen afin de pacifier
al'approche de l'été une situation qui
devient merci merci monsieur le
président la parole à en nommer reyes
koffi ministre chargé de la
décentralisation
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur monsieur président karl le la
solidarité gouvernementale fait qu'à
l'heure actuelle le président de la
république accompagné par le ministre de
l'intérieur se trouve sur les sites
mêmes en hautes pyrénées et dans les
pyrénées dans les hautes pyrénées et
dans les hauts de garonne donc le
président mise d'ailleurs m'a chargé de
vous apporter la réponse à la question
qui est la vôtre vous avez d'abord
rappelé les circonstances dans
lesquelles l'adjoint au maire de cette
commune de frangy a été agressée s'est
trouvé avec un et le nez fracturés et
pour essayer d'éviter que des gens du
voyage ne viennent s'installer de façon
illicite sur un site qui effectivement
n'étaient pas disposés à aller à les
accueillir puisque aussi bien dans cette
commune qui est de moins de 5000
habitants il n'y a pas de site qui soit
distingué pour accueillir je voudrais
avant de répondre à spécifiquement à
votre question dire combien le ministre
d'intérieur mais le gouvernement tout
entier veut saluer l'engagement de
l'ensemble des élus qui tous les jours
ne comptent pas leurs efforts pour
répondre à tous les problèmes qui se
posent pour apporter une médiation
chaque fois que possible sur les
différentes circonstances sur lesquelles
ils sont interpellés et qui dans tous
les cas dans tous les cas cherche à
apporter les meilleures solutions alors
s'agissant du problème particulier que
vous avez exposé sur la haute savoie je
voudrais vous assurer et je le fais en
lien avec madame taubira notre garde des
sceaux que l'ensemble des mesures ont
été prises pour que l' enquête soit
immédiatement et radicalement engagé et
que soient menées avec la plus grande
rigueur pour préciser les circonstances
exactes dans lesquelles s'est passée
cette agression dans lesquelles se sont
passées ces circonstances parce que bien
entendu il n'est en aucun cas acceptable
qu'un élu de la république se trouve
agressée dans les circonstances que vous
avez rappelé et c'est un point auquel
nous tenons particulièrement alors au
delà des désordres que vous avez rappelé
cela ceux de la seine et marne et puis
d'autre que vous avez évoqué le je
voudrais indiquer qu'il n'est en aucun
cas
qu en aucun cas nous ne remettrons en
cause le choix des gens du voyage qui
ont choisi de vivre une vie non
sédentaires mais de la même façon il
sera exigé qu'ils mettent en oeuvre
aussi bien leurs devoirs que leurs
droits et dans des équilibres que l'on
attend bien entendu du respect de la loi
parmi ces mâts de nos missions il y a
parmi ces dispositions il ya celles qui
protègent le droit propriété et donc sur
ce droit de propriété il n'est pas
acceptable que nous ne revenions que
nous ne mettions pas en oeuvre
délibérément les mesures prises
notamment celles qui sont à tout moment
arrêté définit avec le conseil national
de
le conseil national de de nos gens du
voyage et sur lesquels nous travaillons
ensemble merci madame la ministre